and i had an obstacle that i then
figured out it gave me that like
validation within myself that for so
many years i was searching for outside
of myself i was searching for my husband
to come home every day and validate me
because i made nice dinner right i was
waiting for validation for my parents to
tell me i was a good wife i was waiting
for validation from so many
external people or things that having
that pivot putting myself in these
situations where i didn't think i was
capable and then going oh my god i'm
actually capable to figure it out
gave me that idea of what else am i
capable of
and that was the thing of i don't know
what i'm capable of i don't know where
i'm going but the idea that who i am
today does not dictate who i can be
tomorrow was so intoxicating
that i was like i need to do more of
this and that's where i started to pivot
and say what life do i actually want and
by golly i'm gonna freaking demand it of
myself
[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast thank you very much for stopping
by today on the show we have lisa bill
you she's an amazing woman that you're
going to learn so many great things
about
she has a book coming out called radical
confidence 10 no bs lessons on becoming
the hero of your own life it's out may
10th the interview you're going to hear
so much about how she's no bs and she
holds herself accountable and how she's
taught herself perspective and how to
shift her mindset and how to be
empowered and really how to use herself
as to be to be the hero and not to wait
for anyone and
she has such amazing stories about how
she learned that lesson
she also has a show called women of
impact she interviews inspiring women
and flattered she did ask me to be on
but she's learned lots of lessons from
them so at the end of the at the end of
the show you'll hear you know what her
biggest lesson
from all these women has been this was
just a really
sweet episode about a lot of inspiration
and just sharing so many stories about
how she became the badass woman that she
is today her and her husband tom started
a company called quest quest nutrition
and you may have heard of it and it was
the fastest growing company going from i
think zero to a billion dollars in five
years maybe the second fastest growing
company at that time so they know how to
be successful they're very determined
people helping others is is um is where
it's at now which she shares that as
well what her life goal is to share with
the world so please enjoy this episode
and thank you for stopping by it really
means a lot i love doing this show and
by you watching it viewing it liking it
subscribing all those things commenting
all of those things really helped me
understand what it is that you're into
um right now i'm learning that a lot of
you are really into um
psychology and
aliens so if you like this episode let
me know so i can interview more people
like lisa uh but anyway enjoy the
episode please if you like what you
heard today please hit the subscribe
button thanks for stopping by it's so
good to see you i mean for those who
don't know i recorded so many of my
podcasts when i first started at your
house i mean you guys were so sweet to
let me use a room and i then i mean like
you even had guests you know like do you
want to interview this person and i mean
like you guys are such trailblazers in
that category you guys turned your house
literally into a studio
yeah we did it was just so wonderful
having you though and like you know i
love surrounding myself with just badass
women i think that you know growing up i
saw um powerful women as being
intimidating but as i got older i
realized that they can be so incredibly
inspiring and so for me just like having
you in my house and being around you and
having like these epic people coming in
and out it was like it's so amazing what
that sort of thing can really have an
impact on you emotionally and so yeah
girl it was an honor and a pleasure
oh god thank you well what what was
responsible for that transition because
i think you're speaking to a lot of
people i mean i can i've i've felt that
way at times too where you know there's
an intimidation factor or sometimes
maybe a jealousy factor to some degree
but what was it that transitioned that
sort of relationship with strong women
from something that was
maybe something you veered away from to
leaning into
yeah i think it's my own mindset i think
growing up you know yeah it's like yeah
of course it's um
you know women growing up women weren't
nice to me right they were the bullies
they were the ones that um you know i
had this one girl i still remember to
this day i was like 11 years old and i
had the hots for the popular boy in
school and we were going on a school
trip and he came up to me and he was
like lisa i want to dance with you at
the school trip now you can imagine i
got teased i had buck teeth i had the
big nose i had like a unibrow um and so
i was like this is the dream come true
and what ended up happening was i go to
the party thinking that i'm about to
have this dance and he's dancing with a
popular girl in school and it turned out
they set me up
so that they
they thought that they purposely made me
think that i was going to dance with the
popular boy and the popular girl was
supposed to be my friend
so you can imagine when you're young and
you get this it's like you do see other
women as threat as intimidation as they
were the ones that were bullying me it
wasn't the boys it was always the girls
um but i think so then i had like i held
on to the insecurity so anytime i saw an
incredible woman it just became a
reflection of how incompetent i felt
that i was my book the difference
between jealousy and envy envy can be
something that you see someone have but
it inspires you right it's like well
we're freaking danican danica can do it
and so can i you know and she's come
from nowhere and by golly i can do it
too but that's freaking empowering and
envy can be beautiful but jealousy to
your point can tell you apart you just
feel worse about yourself being around
that person and you know it is something
that you strive for but it really just
reflects why you haven't gotten it
versus which i use now is like a
beautiful inspiration and um so yeah i
think growing up i realized that i was
insecure with myself it was actually my
own feelings that i had about myself
that were really echoing how i saw other
women and it wasn't until i started
working on my own mindset and how i felt
about myself and taking ownership over
stepping up to the plate with bad in
hand and swinging as hard as i can even
if i miss that gave me the encouragement
to be like how did she do it that's
amazing maybe i can do it too
wow
bold and brave and
really difficult like i don't think
people understand how hard it is to even
get to the point that you can start to
see yourself
in an equation like i think most people
go through life pretty asleep to this
dynamic
and so how did you wake up
this is one of these this is literally
why i wrote the book radical confidence
because the point was is that girl i
spent eight years what i call stuck and
i call it i was in purgatory the mundane
i didn't hit rock bottom when you've hit
rock bottom and you're like there's
nowhere else to go well i may as well
try for this and in that effort to try
you then succeed so many people i've
interviewed were there but for me i
never hit rock bottom so i ended up
spending eight years of my life in
purgatory my life was just mundane
enough i had a roof over my head i had a
husband that loved me and so each day
because i wasn't in desperation i was
actually talking myself out of changing
my life because i would say to myself
well who do you think you are like being
ungrateful for not having
you know a career that you're excited
about when you've got a roof over your
head and you know how ungrateful you
lisa that you're saying you don't want
to put clothes out for your husband
anymore because i literally spent eight
years taking care of my husband i was a
supportive wife i was putting his
clothes out for him and putting his
lunch and dinner out every single day
that was my purpose in life
and i started to feel like this wasn't
the life i wanted this was the life my
parents told me i was gonna have this
was the life my grandparents being greek
orthodox told me i was going to have but
it wasn't the life i wanted and every
time that feeling of like but this isn't
the dream i had
i would convince myself but you should
be grateful that you have a husband that
loves you and this is where i kind of
found myself in this place of gratitude
is beautiful when you have a
slip into a victim mentality and you're
like why me being grateful is amazing it
really does highlight all the beautiful
things that are happening in your life
but it also for me ended up keeping me
stuck because i was so still talking
about how grateful i was i ended up not
saying hang on a minute yes you can be
grateful for having a husband of your
dreams you can be grateful for having a
beautiful home and yet you can be
totally utterly miserable and want more
in other parts of your life and one
doesn't dictate the other
and so that realization girl hit me like
a freaking ton of bricks and it was
quest that pulled me out of shaking me
awake damn that was awesome i think
that's so cool of you to say because so
many people
uh you know gratitude is everything and
just practice that every day and what an
epiphany did was there a breaking moment
or was this like a culmination of time
that all of a sudden just made you turn
around and go
what the hell am i doing
yeah it's this is the thing i wish it
was a lightning rod moment and i can say
everyone at home that's listening wait
for this moment and you're good the
problem wasn't it wasn't and just like
it was stepping stones small little
decisions that i made for eight years
that kept me stuck it ended up being
small little decisions that ended up
taking me into a life that i didn't
realize was possible and that's why i
wrote the book is like how do i break
people of that notion of what is
possible and what we have
the right to ask for and that was the
thing i started to notice people saying
lisa i want i want confidence like you i
want your confidence and i'd be like who
are they talking to i'm not confident
like you should hear the voice in my
head about telling me all the things
that i'm bad at i would look around like
oh they think i'm confident but what
they just see is someone that moves
forward
and they think it's confidence they
think i feel good about myself and so if
i can shake that feeling of confidence
and help people pivot it's not about
feeling amazing all the time it's about
saying i want confidence to
do this find out what this is and now
focus on that so like for you right and
not i want to like you know like put put
myself in your position but like i want
to be the fastest you know race car
driver in the world it's like
okay like that's the goal not hey i want
confidence to get in the car how do you
take those steps first of all number one
again i'm not going to pretend that i
know but number one is like get in the
car and hold the steering wheel number
two go at 10 miles an hour number three
go at 50 miles an hour it becomes these
stepping stones to get to that goal but
all you're doing is looking at that
audacious goal and saying i want the
confidence to do that you don't get
started so the whole thinking to me is
how do we start to step out of and back
to your question of how did i end up
making that pivot in my life it was
small little decisions that i had made
that i realized i'm stuck
and then this isn't the life i want and
that then led to
i just want to be happy what does happy
mean i don't freaking know but right now
it isn't what we're doing
and that caused me to say but what would
happiness look like and so i said to my
husband i don't care how much money
we've made on paper at the time we were
just chasing money this was before quest
he was working so many hours and he was
coming home and he was really miserable
and so i said i'm fed up with chasing
money i just want a happy husband i want
a happy relationship what would that
look like and that started the catalyst
of tom going in and quitting his job as
he quit his job his business partner
said oh my god we're unhappy too let's
actually sell the company and do
something else that notion then started
if we were doing something else what
would we enjoy doing
let's try the protein bar company that
was the idea that came to it and then
tom came home and he's like babe do you
mind just helping out because i just
thought that as long as i'm supporting
my husband right now that's my future so
when he said we're starting a protein
bar company because we're unhappy will
you help us of course i'll help babe i'm
good greek wife and so but what we
didn't expect is the company grew at 57
000
i went from helping my husband out on
the living room floor shipping bars
weighing peanut butter on home scales
and we were renting a kitchen by the
hour with like knives and rolling pins
to you know within two years we had 10
000 square feet of space i had 40
employees and you know working just
underneath me alone half of them had
criminal backgrounds but um they were
incredible people but being five foot
one i had to every day basically show up
to be like you're gonna let these people
push you around are you gonna you know
be able to lead and that continuous
facing myself every day not knowing my
not having skills learning every day
saying okay lisa you can go into this
not knowing it and learn or you can say
yeah this is too scary but if i don't do
it i lose my house because our house was
up for collateral
so in that pressure
yeah but in that process right it didn't
give me the luxury of saying well i
don't know how to run a team i don't
even know how to you know um to build a
a warehouse i didn't give myself the
luxury and every time i didn't give
myself the luxury and i found had an
obstacle that i then figured out
it gave me that like
validation within myself that for so
many years i was searching for outside
of myself i was searching for my husband
to come home every day and validate me
because i made nice dinner right i was
waiting for validation for my parents to
tell me i was a good wife i was waiting
for validation from so many
external people or things
that having that pivot putting myself in
these situations where i didn't think i
was capable and then going oh my god i'm
actually capable to figure it out gave
me that idea of what else am i capable
of
and that was the thing of i don't know
what i'm capable of i don't know where
i'm going but the idea that who i am
today does not dictate who i can be
tomorrow was so intoxicating that i was
like i need to do more of this and
that's where i started to pivot and say
what life do i actually want and by
golly i'm gonna freaking demand it of
myself
yeah you and tom are such like
go-getters you guys are crazy
um because i know he has so much of this
in him too
um
this feels like the book is called
radical confidence but this feels like a
whole lot of radical honesty it really
is like thinking outside the box and
being honest with yourself is 100 a
massive key and the reason why i called
it radical confidence was going back to
everyone was just like at least how do
you get your confidence i'm like it's so
not confident like confidence is when
you feel great and you've got swagger
and you're like yeah i got this i'm so
far from that danica i'm like oh my god
lisa what on earth are you doing you
have the audacity to try writing a book
you've never bloody written a book
before but hey you know what i don't
have the confidence but i'm going to
freaking figure it out and i'm going to
take all of my insecurities all of my
inadequacies because i am inadequate to
writing a book because i've never
written a book before and give myself
the grace to frickin learn and freaking
stumble and literally every time i fall
on the floor lisa you're going to give
yourself the beauty and the grace to
pick yourself up that is radical
confidence that's going in not
pretending like you know everything but
saying i've got a tool belt
and i'm going to use whatever tool i
need in this moment when i'm scared to
move forward with radical confidence and
that is why i needed to write the book
and i treated it like each chapter is a
tool or a skill set that you can
cultivate in order to do this i know
that perception is something that you
have talked about a lot being being
really important and as you're going
through the way that you feel about
something whether if it's difficult it
it doesn't mean you're not acknowledging
that it's difficult but
there's a whole lot of a perception
shift on going instead of i can't do
this i don't know how to do this i'm not
capable of doing this you say i don't
know how to do this but i'm going to
figure it out and i will and i will get
stronger as a result
and i'm wondering like when
perception and perspective
was something that entered your psyche
maybe and maybe it's in parallel with
with this lesson but do you remember
when that in particular came through for
you to go like oh [ __ ] if i just look at
it like that
or maybe looking in hindsight going i've
done that a couple times and it's like
totally worked for me do you remember
how you grew in that area of shifting
your perspective yeah i love this topic
there's so many um
that there's there's two that really
come to mind one business and one
personal one of the biggest lessons i
ever learned was a moment so i've had
massive gut issues massive gut issues so
about six years ago it's been like 20
years of not having a good relationship
with foods cutting out fat getting sick
a lot taking too many antibiotics so
i've had a real struggle with my gut
and it got to the point where
my gut felt like it erupted that's the
best explanation i can have and when it
when that happened
for about a year ago i couldn't stand up
for longer than five minutes at a time i
was 20 pounds lighter than you see me
now and now my hair was falling out my
nails were brittle and i couldn't wear
like a bra for six months i mean i was
in agony constantly and i could barely
eat anything so i was completely
malnutritioned i you know mood swings
emotional just because i couldn't eat
six years ago this happened i'm still on
the journey to recovery i've identified
a lot of issues um but in saying all of
that just to give context to this story
so i'm in gut disarray on most days but
i don't tell people because i don't want
to appear weak i do my job i've got a
strong mindset crush it lisa and then
feel weak when you're by yourself like
that was my mentality
and so i
i'm on a photo shoot and it's in my
house and it's a big day all excited
um got my hair my makeup done i'm on set
and all of a sudden my stomach starts to
cramp and i'm like oh god oh god is this
about to happen like am i about to like
drop to my knees because it was that
painful sometimes so i excused myself i
go upstairs and i actually drop to my
knees and i'm like crutch clutching my
side and i'm breathing deeply now me and
my husband have a rule in our
relationship
if you need the other person you can
call them now i can ignore your first
phone call
if i'm busy i can actually do your
second your second phone call if you
call me three times in a row it doesn't
matter who you're with if i'm
interviewing oprah
i literally would have to put down and
go sorry oprah my husband's called me
three times it's an emergency i've gotta
go that's how like our rule is strict
and so i'm on i'm on the floor i call
him the first time he calls me i call
him the second time he ignores me i call
him the third time he doesn't answer and
now i'm on the floor and i'm clutching
my stomach i've got a whole film crew
downstairs and i'm like oh my god i need
my husband i need my husband what the
hell am i going to do how am i going to
get up i need my husband
i need my husband and in that moment i
was like you don't need him
you want him
lisa get the f up because you're your
own hero you don't need someone to save
you you can freaking save yourself
get
up i remember that so freaking clearly
and girl i got up off the floor i took
deep breaths and i finished off the day
now that story stayed with me for six
years
because in that moment perspective into
perspective
i had a way of thinking i need someone
to come rescue me
and in that change of perspective where
i said lisa you are your own hero you do
not wait for someone to come and rescue
you
you look at the problem and you handle
it yourself that's basically what the
conclusion was and from that day on any
time i struggle i go are you looking
outside yourself or you're
or are you your own freaking hero like
answer that honestly because if you're
your own hero what on earth are you
going to do to get yourself out of it
put on your damn cape and start flexing
and show what you're made of and that
perspective
changed everything in business it's all
my fault it's the language i like to use
because it stings if a business
something goes wrong lisa it's all your
fault what would you do differently if
something's wrong in my relationship
lisa assume it's all your fault don't
look at your husband because then i can
actually make the change i can take the
power back now look that's not actually
saying sometimes it always is your fault
of course it's not but that perspective
that freaking ownership that mindset of
if it's all on you what are you gonna do
differently
changed my life
well you're not off base because i have
a saying
that's very similar where i say your
life is your fault but that includes
everything being the hero
being your own victim
achieving greatness failing miserably
like feeling sad feeling really ecstatic
like it's all your fault
how do you find people when you say that
do people push back on you
yeah i mean it's kind of like it doesn't
get a lot of reaction because i think it
provokes a lot of thought
you know when you say your life is your
fault you're like first off it sounds
negative so you go hmm and then you go
it's kind of like what do you mean it's
like i mean everything i mean everything
and that's kind of it's um it's almost
as hard to acknowledge the good as it is
the bad sometimes
you know when people were telling you
when you were pushing through
you're so strong and you're so confident
i'm gonna tell you that they were just
mirroring that you were
now they didn't know your true total
reality and they didn't know your weaker
moments but you were confident and
strong when you went to work and pushed
through like they were showing you you
and in fact the our life is always
showing us uh who we are i actually do
get sometimes pushback on the word fault
because the discussion becomes and i
actually understand it but it's like
well aren't you um blaming people it's
like victimization and i really sat with
that because i do like to evolve and so
i sat with and i was like it doesn't
feel true to me but if multiple people
are saying i need to listen if the word
fault works for me because it does like
sting it actually does trigger me it's
like all my fall
but it creates an activation in me and
that's what i love and i think that's
the key is like guys don't get freaking
caught up in the word if all actually
triggers you negatively don't use it but
use the word that impacts you enough to
act and that word for that's why i love
it because every time i say least it's
your fault it does sting and that sting
creates that well [ __ ] i don't want to
feel like that again so i better do
something differently you you talked
about a little bit with that story and
wait before we go there was a was there
two stories you said there was a
personal one and then the other one so
this is a business one where we it's
quest early days three of us that we've
hired and then the us the rest is just
like us
who own the company and so we hire we're
doing a production line a production run
so we've got peanut butter bar that
we're making and then a mixed berry bar
and then like the lemon bar
one of the guys comes in to the office
and he's got like this ghostly look on
his face and what's wrong and he's like
oh my god i'm so sorry i'm so sorry now
i'm a panicker so i stopped panicking so
i'm like oh my god what's what's wrong
and he's like i've just messed up a
batch of bars now in these early days a
batch of bars is five thousand dollars
which is at that point it's like make or
break for your business so i'm panicking
the guy thinks he's about to get fired
my husband very like my husband being a
very calm cool guy he's like well before
you panic baby let's just get up and
like see what we've got so we walk in
guys like oh my god i'm so sorry i was
making the peanut butter batch and i get
the peanut butter flour i get the peanut
butter protein powder i get the peanuts
and he's like and then i get the mixed
berry flavoring and he's like and i put
the wrong flavoring from the next flavor
into the currant bar we're like oh no
and tom's like before everyone panics
let's just try and i'm like babe what
like what the hell are we going to do
and we all take a bite and we hold our
breath
and someone's like you know what it
tastes like pb and j
and in that moment
when we were about to lose five thousand
dollars trash product that we thought
could potentially take us bankrupt we
saw an opportunity
so we wrap them and we're like
guys here's a new prototype pb and j
yeah we wrap it in like the the clear
wrapper so it's got like no description
we get blank boxes we print out my
staples printer the peanut butter
nutritional information because the
nutrition information was still the same
because the only thing that changed was
the flavoring so we print it out on my
printer we put it in these 200 boxes we
make this big announcement on facebook
at the time saying limited edition
prototype only 200 boxes girl they
freaking sold out like that
ah
then a couple of days later people
started posting on facebook how much
they love the flavor and so now all the
people that didn't even get a chance to
buy it started really having major fomo
they start freaking out saying hang on a
minute i want to try this new pb j
flavor what you know how come i didn't
get a chance to buy one and now
before you know it within a month we get
designs made wrappers made and it
becomes our number one pro selling
protein bar on the market at the time
come on
that is how you have a massive mistake
and a massive failure and see it as the
most beautiful opportunity
wow and that is a shift in perspective
wow that's a great story for sure for
sure
um okay i was gonna ask you about your
health stuff because i am very curious
because i think it's easy you know it's
it's
i think it's something that speaks to a
lot of people i personally have been
going through my own stuff in the last
year and it's very frustrating not
nearly to the point that probably what
you're talking about that you are but
but actually i think what you just said
in working with tom and that i'm really
curious about working with your husband
and like you guys talk so much about
relationship stuff and it's really good
stuff like
i mean i read all your like boards that
you make and write your bullet points on
it and i'm like yes that's so good like
how the heck if anybody doesn't follow
you guys they should because you guys
are so open and you share so much and
you have such good information so how
that i mean how long have you guys been
married now we're about to celebrate our
20-year wedding anniversary wow
congratulations thank you i have the
confidence you're going to make it there
yeah i'm sure
um how did you get to that point like
share some relationship advice maybe
what where did you guys get to the point
where you can even like even just the
fact that you have like a three-call
rule like i don't know if my
relationships have barely ever had rules
of any kind like i don't know
go we have you know so many rules it is
like it's comical but it's been so
important to our relationship because of
that reason right because you don't
think the same you don't act the same so
let's say for me i really need like it's
an emergency but
his version of an emergency is very
different to my first version of
emergency so let's say i feel like it's
an emergency he doesn't and now what
happens i think he's being dismissive
but he just doesn't have the same
foundation of what an emergency means to
him so we have not only those rules but
language if i use the word important
like if he literally walked in right now
as we're doing this interview and i said
babe i need to speak to as important he
would drop everything's like what do you
need because i use the word important
that specific word
maybe three times a year
maybe
but we've defined what that word
important means so we've got like these
like dictionary definitions or when i
say important it means that i don't bs
and in 20 in our relationship in 22
years only once has the word important
clashed with each other
so i've said one thing is important to
me and then he said it's important as
well only once that's how like
we provide that word so if he says it
i'm like yeah it's not important okay
you you know it's for you okay what do
we need to do um only once in 22 years
we've clashed over the word important
um rules about um
who's who's the responsible party to
wave the flag when we're no longer that
really intimate connection you know like
relationships all ebb and flow they do
it's all natural but you need someone in
the party who is the responsible party
that says hey when i speak up and i say
this it means that we both have to pay
attention because i'm the one that
notices it first so for instance tom can
go longer without having date night than
i can
and so but he normally if i don't speak
up when he notices that's when we start
to argue and start to notice friction
so we've realized oh lisa actually is
better at identifying it because when i
wave the flag we actually get to the
point where we reconnect before we start
bickering
amazing so now what we do is we just
decide but we decide together so that
when i do wave the flag he doesn't turn
around and just being needy right he's
like oh yep she's waved the flag we've
agreed when she says this word it means
drop everything we have to spend time
together so it's having these like
really like this rule book
and then we ask each other hard
questions because we really want
our relationship together is our number
one priority so for instance if i tell
him something that he doesn't want to
hear but he knows my priority is our
relationship he's going to listen
but when you know someone's saying
something to you but really your goal
is the same
then they have your interest at heart as
well so when he comes to me tells me
things of hey when you do this fxr
relationship
because i know his number one
north star is have a wonderful
relationship with me i know he's coming
from purity now look that takes years to
prove over and over again it takes
moments of i tell him something that is
very um let's say very vulnerable like i
expose my trigger to him let's say and
it's something that's so personal to me
and i've only ever told him
in moments of massive fights in
arguments does he use it against you yes
or no
those are the do you use it against them
even when it's easy for them to do it do
they do it and that starts to show
character
and in those moments where you get
tested where things get hard
who are you and who is your character
and for instance in the last 20 years
when people say oh my god you're so
lucky how do you guys you know stay
around and i was like look
if i was married to someone else
i don't know if i'd still be married if
he was married to someone else i don't
know if he'd still be married because
it's when the hard times come that test
you so for instance when i married my
husband i told him babe i want four
children that was my dream i want four
kids i want a big greek family
now flash forward seven uh nine years i
start a quest i find myself i love
entrepreneurship and i turn around and
say hey baby you know for eight years
i've taken care of every single thing
you've ever needed on a personal front
you know how i said i want four children
well now i don't want to put out any
clothes to you i never want to cook for
you again i want to be an entrepreneur
and i don't want any children
in those moments yeah
in those moments so it becomes a how did
i handle it and how did we communicate
through it and how did we get through to
the other end because with a different
person with different communication
skills it would have been like well
screw you you're changing the game you
told me you wanted four children you
know you're you're changing it's not me
you either stick to your you know what
you promised you would be or i want to
divorce right or there's another
scenario well i don't say that and now i
stay at home for the next 20 years more
because i'm miserable but i know
if i say something i'm going to lose my
husband so there's so many scenarios but
in those situations
me and my husband we tested we didn't
mean to right but we tested ourselves
and so i went into it saying i recognize
i'm the one changing i recognize i'm the
one saying hey i no longer want to do
this
so how do i approach him with grace and
show him that i recognize it because you
know what it's like when someone comes
in and they like pretend like i don't
understand what what's your problem like
why can't you just accept it now you're
like they don't even give me the the
beauty or the grace to say yes i am
willing to adapt like people you kind of
want to pound the bag i've been like
this is difficult but i'm still willing
to do it i'm robbing him of that if i
just come in and say well babe you're
going to have to accept this is who i am
so
i didn't think that was fair
so don't rob them of what the change so
i went in saying babe i recognize i'm
changing
i recognize that this is going to take
time
i recognize that we are playing a game
with tennis but we're on the same side
and so as my partner you know when you
like hit the ball and then your your
partner has it because you've missed it
that's me and my husband and that's who
we've agreed to be so i'm like babe
right now i'm missing the ball like i'm
really struggling with the life that i
have and i you know wasn't this eloquent
but i'm like kind of translating
and so as my partner i need you to help
me win the game
and right now i'm struggling so how do
we win the game together and so now he
feels like i'm turning to him as a
partner
yeah and men need to be needed
yes i mean so do we right so yeah like
we feel good about it
and i didn't want to whoop him over that
it's like look i do need help i need
help with transitioning from this
stay-at-home wife of eight years now i'm
literally telling you i don't want to
put your clothes out but babe i don't
want it to be you to think it's a
reflection of how much i love you so we
had to talk through that it's like this
is why i don't want to do it because it
makes me profoundly unhappy
but it's got nothing to do with you and
to show that it's got nothing to do with
you
let's come up with a plan together
on how we work through this transition
and so i joked but i was like it's kind
of like i'm weaning him off and so i was
like all right babe for now i put
clothes out and cook for you seven days
a week but let's wing you off i'll do it
for six days a week and then i'll do it
for five days a week and then i'll do it
for four because i recognize i'm
changing and so how do we do it together
how do i show you respect that i it's
going to have to be a process it's not
like hey
you know mf you're gonna have to just
deal with it right it's showing them
respect that you're giving them a chance
to transition
slowly and then
why we're doing it this is the most
beautiful thing i've ever done and i
didn't think babe that being an
entrepreneur and trying these skills and
creating impact was a life that i would
have but now that i do
i've never felt more alive than i do now
and i want your help to help fan these
flames you said why
and knowing your why is also something
you've mentioned before yeah right
because that's
such an anchor right 100
so what are your whys for everything
right why for why in your room why your
relationship with tom why
why your show women have impact why
the new book like what are your buckets
of wise
yeah having the why though has changed
everything because i have such a
negative voice i don't know if you do
and i'm really curious to know i
actually do i have a fairly negative
voice i'm pretty self-critical
i'm actually really positive for a lot
for most everything else and very
attitudinal and very
encouraging but my own self-talk is kind
of [ __ ]
yeah what do you do when that happens
well sometimes you just do it and you
live with what it feels like because
that's just the point right
um sometimes it motivates me to do
things
um to be more motivated to
you know schedule some more meetings and
plan some more things and get more
organized or maybe it's uh
to work out or maybe it's to stay on my
diet or whatever it may be it's like
there's always there's sometimes it can
be motivating um but other times it can
just get exhausting and i think in those
times where you just kind of are like
over yourself almost in the whole thing
you just gotta flip it and you just
gotta put some perspective on and be
like it doesn't really matter and also i
think it's really powerful to shift it
and flip it
like
if the things that you're worrying about
were someone else's how would you like
flip it what would you be thinking about
them and a lot of times you'd be like
nothing like they'd be great i wouldn't
have a negative thing like it you'd
you'd be you'd be like that's such a
small problem or
no one even notices
and so flipping it kind of gives some
perspective even the things that you
just said and given very like tactical
tools like i'll go work out i'll go do
this because that's the point is that
sometimes i can't get out of my own head
and the voice is so loud that like i
can't turn her down call of a [ __ ] in
my head like i can't turn her down i
can't turn her out she's so freaking
loud and so in those moments what are
the things i go to what tools do i use
to shut her out so working out is a
massive thing for me lifting weights
um but i know someone has shown me that
yeah
um
but having the why the why is huge for
me because
i use it as a way with no judgment and i
use that word a lot with no judgement of
what's more important so let's say for
instance i'm really feeling insecure
about myself and i'm about to try
something new and it's got like like who
do you think you are lisa you're gonna
be terrible like you're gonna bomb
you're gonna embarrass yourself like
people are gonna say i can't believe
like tom was great at this but can you
believe lisa how bad she was right like
that's the voice that's going in my head
and i actually don't judge myself for
and i'm like okay that's the voice but
if you listen to her this is the impact
you're not going to create
but if you don't listen to her and you
follow your why what can you do so when
i think about my why being let's say the
14 year old girl
who i honestly when i think about my why
like the super like my freaking north
star it is creating content for 14 year
old girls to believe in them to make
them believe in themselves they don't
spend the next 20 years unwiring the
negative mindset i've had to one wire
so in moments where i'm fearful of like
writing a book or in moments where i'm
like stepping in front of the camera and
i'm so freaking embarrassed and like i
can't believe the you know the imposter
syndrome comes in going lisa you know
you in front of the camera who do you
think you are i just say with no
judgment would you rather be completely
insecure
and create impact on that 14 year old
girl or would you rather protect your
ego and not do it and now
in moments like that don't judge
yourself just decide
yeah that's right
and it's okay right like it's who who
should be who on earth can judge me or
should judge me no one if i decide look
right now if i do this my ego would be
so hurt it's not the life i want it's my
freaking life i can do what i want yeah
but if i decide
and i do time and time again that i want
to be a little uncomfortable because
that 14 year old needs me you better
believe i'm gonna keep moving forward so
back to your point of the why it's so
important to know exactly what is
pulling at your heartstrings like be so
succinct in that mission
so that when you face yourself time and
time again when you really feel
inadequate you've got that thing that
you can go to
is so
what is your why to our like define it
simply and maybe you have multiple is it
just one why or yeah so it's one central
why so it really is to create content
that impacts 14 year old girls to
believe in themselves so that they don't
spend the next 20 years having to unwind
the negative mindset so the reason why
i have it so succinct is i need to know
my why the what and the who
so i need to know why i'm doing it i'm
doing it to prevent 14 year old actually
i should back up the who 14 year old
girls the what creating content because
there's so many things we could do right
it's like i could um donate my time and
um you know help a school of female
girls it's like there's so many
different ways that i can create impact
but i need to know how so for me my
background's filmmaking so it's the
content it's the who the 14 year old
girl because the age of imprint is
between like third 12 to 15 of where we
are shaped to be basically who we are
for the rest of our lives now look we're
very malleable so 50 of our brain we can
be malleable as we get older like the
things that we're talking about now
but when it comes to a foundation of who
we are that gets shaped between 11 and
15 years old
so if i can impact culture and impact
the way young girls feel about
themselves with the content that is out
there so that's movies animation tv
shows music
all of these type books all of these
types of things that if i can impact
culture
to a girl that is at that age where now
they're wiring their mindset to actually
believe in themselves
now all this stuff we do as adults we're
like i can retire i don't have to do
content based on adults and how we
unwire because now we've impacted all
the young girls are already like
building that foundation of believing in
themselves from the get-go
that's a big role that's a big role to
fill i feel like in this day and age
especially with how
challenging social media is and
entertainment and
algorithms and i mean like it's like
it's like a it's a sharks it's it's
shark-infested waters
especially for women men are men too but
i think women especially there's
there's something different about it why
do you think women
is harder i mean i'm i'm i'm guessing
that you think this it's maybe harder
for women than men
so to do what specifically social
sciences
yeah i do here it is
yeah i 100 do agree with that um i think
that
it's definitely changing as well
um i think so much of it is cultural so
much of it is social so like for
instance me bef i didn't grow up i'm 42.
so i didn't grow up with social media
but cultural pressure of being greek
orthodox and being told subliminally all
along the way as i was growing up that i
would end up being a stay-at-home wife
um it was exactly how i ended up i think
being a stay-at-home wife because i
didn't question it so that is like i
think the biggest fear of what are the
messages that we're um that we believe
so ingrained in us that we don't even
question like i will
i remember and i'd love to hear from you
entering such a
male dominant you know a world where
actually now i hear
a lot of women say oh a lot of companies
now need more women so they're actually
being sought after more but i can only
imagine based when you started like that
was not the case at all you were like
groundbreaking smashing through barriers
of what it was possible for women to do
um probably part of the help for me was
that my
dad my mom and dad my dad especially
there was never a talk about being a
girl or different like it
it was obvious but it wasn't obvious if
that makes sense it wasn't until i
started at 10 it wasn't until 14 when i
started to be featured in tv shows and
cameras were coming to school and the
track that i started to
even think about really being a girl
that much
wow
that's fascinating you're right your
environment matters so my environment
was not about being the fastest girl or
well you're doing pretty good for a girl
it was like how do you be the best
driver
right and not even the best driver but
how do you be your best because like
being a half a second quicker than
everybody was still not enough if i
could go faster does that make sense so
it's like my threshold not even
not even against the just the guys or
just the girls or just the guys it was
against myself so um
yeah yeah and i think that's probably
why very much my i feel like my purpose
now is to help people understand
um
how much potential they hold within
themselves
and that's so powerful
i wonder if how much has contributed to
your success oh i'm sure yeah just
because i didn't have the perception of
being different it was never phrased as
being different and so you know you
sharing your story about just what a
woman's supposed to do and how their
life is supposed to go and you know that
framed your reality and the fact that my
reality was framed around being not only
the fastest driver but
even you know as fast as i could humanly
go that was my mindset was how do i be
the fastest period
and so yeah i'm sure that played a huge
role i i really do
um one area i'm curious about because i
i'm
again i shared a little bit i'm that i'm
kind of in a little bit of it as well
but you know with health struggles how
did you deal with that mentally because
i mean that can be i mean i mean again i
don't think i'm dealing with half of
your stuff by any means but you know
it's perpetuating it's day after day
it's how you feel
it's testing it's trials of things it's
you know modalities to try and help
things i mean it's like quite endless
and it can be kind of exhausting and
consuming and have its own perpetuating
cycle of feeling like oh you know poor
me something's wrong with me and that
kind of is a very very very repetitive
narrative so
share whatever you're willing to share
about that because you're not alone in
that in dealing with things i think a
lot of women push things under the rug
but maybe sharing what you went through
and then how you dealt with it because
you really are like superwoman now
and thinking i don't know how much
you're willing to share on this but
obviously anything i can do that maybe
you know advice if i've been through or
can help please do let me know and this
is one of my missions because it changed
my life and so when i think about um how
do we or how do i help people not get
there in the first place and what are
the things because everything became in
hindsight
um one of the things actually in just
the healing process is i going back to
ownership i was waiting for a doctor to
fix me so when it happened first of all
i was like okay what's the right pill i
have to take and hey doctor what's wrong
right and you literally go to the doctor
and you're like okay this is this doctor
came recommended and this person has a
special degree and they've got famous
people on their wall you convince
yourself that an expert quote-unquote is
going to help fix
you
and every time i went there i had hope
and every time i left i had zero hope
yeah and but it was the hope i was
chasing really in hindsight right so i
think i just kept going to the doctor
being like okay well this one's gonna
this one's gonna fix me and eventually
what i ended up realizing was i was
actually giving my power away
so by looking outside of myself by
looking to a doctor to say hey can you
um fix me i was giving it away now i
didn't come to that conclusion though
until i realized i'd actually all the
things that went wrong with my own
health were due to me so once i started
to process and i looked back why did i
get so sick i was like you know what i
took a lot of antibiotics like a lot it
got to the point where i was on
antibiotics like four times a year or
five times a year because i was getting
so sick all the time
so originally
i was blaming the doctors well he
shouldn't give me that many antibiotics
and after a while after two years of
literally just searching for someone to
help and save me once i realized i saved
myself
i literally was like hang on a minute i
keep saying they gave me antibiotics but
i swallowed them
every time a doctor said yeah
right it's like every time a doctor kept
saying you know i probably shouldn't
give you this many antibiotics not once
did i say why not and not once did i go
home and google what does to take in too
many antibiotics lead to
and so once i started to realize
that by telling saying that it was
therefore i was now giving the power
away once i switched it
and said
this is all my fault and if it was my
fault now i can fix it and fit what does
fixing look like i stopped turning to
doctors i acknowledged that i had
done it to myself that i was ignoring
the flags you even said right we pushed
under the rug
i now had to stop and pause and say what
was i actually pushing under the rug
what did that look like okay when i had
this pain i did this okay did that serve
me right like when i was you know on the
floor holding my gut i sucked it up and
went to another four hours of a photo
shoot all right well did that serve me
yes or no no that didn't serve me okay
so next time lisa
next time you fall on the floor
you're going to say
i'm taking the rest of the day off right
like coming up with rules that when this
happens because you've already been
there and you have control and you're
the one that is going to heal yourself
because it's all your fault you have to
come up with a game plan
and so with no judgment i res
that replayed all the red flags that
happened i started to say when this flag
happens i'm gonna do this when i wake up
tired i'm going to do this when i get a
stomach crack up cramp i'm going to do
this and i took ownership and that meant
i got an oar ring because i was waking
up tired all the time and i'm like i'm
sleeping like nine now
why am i tired all the time
so i wore an orange i wore a continuous
glucose monitor
and i started to assess i started to
write down i go to bed at nine o'clock
in the evening i would wake up according
to my aura ring at 2 a.m
and according to my glucose monitor i
would have actually crashed at around
150. oh hypoglycemia oh
is there a correlation between my blood
sugars and how much i sleep
how was i feeling the next day i felt
exhausted all right what time did i eat
dinner well you ate dinner at 8 p.m okay
i went to bed at 9. what if i ate two
hours in between what if i ate three
hours in between what if i went keto
like i literally
tried everything and i wrote everything
down and then
i went and said
you know when you say trust your gut
it's like how many of us ignore our gut
oh
all of us many times i mean most of the
time
yes i mean but
ask anyone how many times your gut was
wrong and they'll be like
um
yeah right
because the problem is that we don't
want to hear it when it's bad we don't
want to hear it when it's like don't do
that we don't want to hear it when it's
like
you should probably get out of that
relationship you know we don't want to
hear it when you shouldn't be treated
like that we don't want to hear it when
you better try that we just want to hear
the oh look there's a butterfly
oh you're doing great this is a 11-11
sign
we don't we we don't want to hear the
bad stuff but
it's because you have to face it right
and look facing it sometimes really
freaking sucks
like facing the hard truth that's why i
wrote the chapter like open up the can
of worms and embrace the ick it's like
sometimes open up the can of worms only
leads to horrible worms and you're like
i don't want to deal with worms so let
me just not open it right like and i
equate it to the hard questions what am
i happy do i actually want to be in this
relationship because to your point what
if the answer is no
and now if you're married what if you've
got kids and your answer is actually i'm
not happy in this relationship now you
have to say well do i have to go to
therapy do i you know i have to tell
them do they want to go to therapy what
if we go to therapy and it doesn't work
what if what if you
find out that they've cheated on me can
i forgive them does that mean we have to
get a divorce i mean we have to sell the
house who gets the kids what happens at
christmas right like
yes
right what if i can't find anyone after
that because now they've actually seen
the truth right there's so many things
that come with it
that i get why it ends up well we don't
want to even ask the freaking question
in the first place because it becomes
easier now i don't know about you but
not once i've had so many therapists on
my show
not one relationship therapist has ever
said
that someone comes in and i was like i
didn't even realize this was over until
today most of the time
they come in like i knew this marriage
was over five years ago
yeah
how often but we we try and it's like
it's actually a beautiful thing about us
as humans we try to make something work
and it's like but only if it's the same
with the health it's like oh well this
will be fine in a week no you'll be fine
to actually ask myself what would life
look like lisa if you had gut issues for
the rest of your life it's too much of a
big audacious question to ask i can't
even comprehend what my life would look
like now remember i said at the
beginning girl i started this i'm six
years in i thought it was going to be a
week
oh god i hear i mean i hear you my like
stuff started with oh it's your thyroid
and i'm like oh great i'll just take
this pill and everything will be perfect
and that was a year ago and that's like
trivial compared to you know the point
that i'm at now and so what happened
then when you
start writing everything down you're
tracking everything
you talked about opening up that can of
worms like yeah did you have to face
something that you didn't want to face
so i had ready to yet um it wasn't that
i wasn't ready to but it was the it was
what i kind of known all along so i was
like i hadn't had a period in so many
years and so i was like guys this
doesn't quite match like i was going i'm
like does my hormones got anything to do
with in my garden like no of course it
doesn't it's that's like but now this
was six years ago we've learned so much
since then as well yeah
it seems weird i haven't had a period
like surely and but doctors don't no no
no so i went in after eventually i'd
owned okay lisa if this was all your
fault what do you have to do i went in
and got my own blood work done i went in
and got my own hormones checked i went
into a um gastroenterologist and um
not gastroenteritis a gynecologist sorry
and
when they like ha this is one of the
most horrifying stories so i go in there
i haven't had my period in years i go
i'm thinking okay you know it's um
i'm sure it's got to do with my health
i'm underweight like if they're going to
tell me like all this diet blah blah
blah
she comes in with a little clipboard and
she goes oh
it looks like actually you've got pcos
like polycystic ovary syndrome
and i'm like oh my god do i she was yeah
oh but it looks it says here that you
don't want children i was like no i then
she because i think you're fine
excuse me she says well if you don't
want children you're fine i'm like i'm
sorry because i don't want kids it's
okay to leave cysts on my ovaries
it was so horrifying and at the same
time so enlightening to how people think
yeah all right
and instead of getting angry at that
point i was like yeah that's about right
that's
that's how other people think and
instead of getting annoyed at them go
lisa this is your life you're taking
ownership over it don't settle for that
doctor going you then you're fine don't
settle for what they were gonna do
because that's what she would do that's
why she's telling you that it's
something like i had a specialist on a
hormone specialist and something like it
takes eight diagnosis
for women's hormones for them to
actually be accurate it's something
crazy like that oh my god
like it's something like on the eighth
doctor they actually get it somewhat
accurate on women's hormones it that's
crazy
i mean i i
i went in for the that the reason why i
went in the doctor last year was for the
same reason i had plenty of other red
flags and symptoms and signs but it was
losing my cycle and i was like all right
this is probably bad you you get those
indicators along the way that were like
shoot this isn't right and it's a matter
of dealing with them so
what i mean
in the end what what was that what was
the big lesson in it
the lesson was that it's an evolution
and
um
every step was a focus of how do i get
progressively better versus how do i get
completely well
and even when i think about business and
i think about everything i do that
really is the goal like what what am i
trying to build what is that skill set
that i can incrementally get better
every day to your point earlier about
you being your own competition right
it's like okay what what number how fast
was i yesterday and how fast can i get
be today um as well as having that big
audacious dream of like i'm gonna get
the world cup or whatever the cup is um
you know and so that's kind of i have
the big audacious dream of one day lisa
you will be perfect but today instead of
being like putting so much weight and
pressure over oh my god i can't believe
i'm not there yet
it's like what's that thing i'm going to
do today so it was things like it takes
three hours for your body to completely
digest your food so
for an entire year you think i'm joking
but to the minute for the entire year i
didn't go to bed once
with three less than three hours from
eating and going to bed so if tom and i
oh infinitely
overnight girl when i'm telling you take
your last from your last swallow so it
would be from the last swallow i would
take ownership i would look at the time
and go oh crap it's 7 p.m i now have to
stay up till 10 p.m now look i'm very
strict on myself i go to bed at 9pm so
if my food got off i would still stick
to the fact that i cannot go to bed with
a full stomach i must go to bed with an
empty stomach so it was go to bed with
an empty stomach for three hours then
start trying foods i don't care what the
doctors say i don't care what studies
say i don't care what all the
specialists say
start eating food and take a journal of
how you feel lisa and what i realized
was that raw food was wrecking my gut if
i ate fatty beef i felt like i was on
cloud nine now i did an allergy test and
guess what the allergy test told me i
was allergic to beef
and what do you think i did girl for a
week
i stopped eating beef even though i i
felt like but it feels really good
because a doctor told me i was like oh
but the doctor knows best
and that was where after i realized
start listening to yourself that's when
i'm like screw the doctors i'm gonna go
on a purely beef diet and see how i feel
i did that for a while i realized i was
feeling much better i realized i
couldn't sustain it though i needed some
form of vegetables i went and got
my blood work done i then went to a
holistic doctor who then was able to
help me work through all my levels and
go okay i was low i was deficient in
vitamin c i was deficient in vitamin b
um i had leaky gut so i started to drink
like this leaky gut liquid consistently
even to the point where if i was
traveling i would have these little
travel bottles of my leaky gut liquid
because i take full ownership and there
wasn't one day that i missed i didn't
use the excuse of oh but i'm traveling
and i can't take liquid on the plane no
no i got one of those little travel
things and i stuck to my regiment and i
had these little supplements and i wish
i had one here to show you i have these
little baggies they're all done pre in
advance so i've got no excuse there's
one that says a.m there's one that says
pm and i will be literally sitting in
meetings it doesn't matter who i'm with
literally doesn't matter who i'm with if
it's time for me to take my supplements
i'll stay here with my little baggie and
i'll drink my supplements and that is
where i go to
listening to the doctor waiting to be
saved waiting to be fixed
and then flipping my perspective and
saying i'm going to take full ownership
what does that look like what does no
excuses look like where do i want to be
in a year and who am i going to be
turning to and it's me and if i'm not
here to actually fulfill the promise
i've made myself then who else can i
rely on no one yeah if you can't fight
for your own freaking goals no one's
gonna fight for them so in that moment
of me being trying to be healthy or like
trying to figure out and you're going to
parties and i'm traveling and my old
mindset was like oh i can't go out i
can't do this you know i can't i just
said no no lisa you can you just choose
not to
and that flip that perspective um
changed everything so if whatever issues
you're going through obviously a however
i can help but then also give yourself
the grace that it's stepping stones and
that really today totally what are you
gonna do today that can help you for
tomorrow and if you end up taking steps
back because sometimes you have a goal
and sometimes like for this book tour
right it's like there's a lot more work
and i'm putting in a lot more hours and
so i have a plan
where i say no matter what i draw
so i use my creativity i draw on
saturday mornings and no matter what
happens i won't let anyone i'm trying to
get good with my boundaries i i put very
strict boundaries i switch my phone off
no one can call me on saturday morning
and reach me because i'm drawing and
you're an incredible artist by the way
you have something to hold up to show
people what you can we're
ridiculously talented i do have in
another room i can always run and go get
my my current work of art oh actually i
have it on my phone well people can find
it on the on social
yeah i mean look at you that's insane
girl i mean that's crazy
whether it's a morning a couple of hours
one hour but i'm telling you anyone that
has health issues anyone that's
listening
do whatever you can to completely shut
the world out and do something that is
just for you whether it's drawing taking
a bath reading the magazine like but it
has to be a specific time that you've
set aside that you're telling people i
am not available to you
and you have to demand that of yourself
and put that boundary up because again
if you're not willing to do that for
yourself no one else is going to you
interview so many amazing women in your
show women of impact so like what are
some high points of things that you've
learned from so many amazing women over
the last how long has the show been
going on now about three give me some
give me some nuggets all right um nugget
so first of all by the way i'm just
going to put you on the spot but homie
i'd have you on in a freaking second by
the way i would love to
um let's make that happen please
in a heartbeat i was like while i'm on
her podcast i'm going to corner her um
good
i was like does she want me on her show
or not it's oh my god in a heartbeat the
funny thing is i was so jealous when you
went on tom
but i knew and this is part of my
personality that i actually lean into
more and i talk about in the in the book
be so good they cannot ignore you
and so i've got a list of people that
i've wanted on my show and it's like i
know when the right i have to be so good
that when i reach out i don't get a no
and it's and it's very empowering for me
though it like going back to actually
what you said earlier about yourself and
the whole kind of theme that i feel like
we've accidentally slipped into here is
like be your own competition so it's
like oh who was i yesterday how do i
beat myself yesterday and show up to be
better so that when i do reach out
people want to come on the show but um
but that's actually a lesson that i've
kind of learned with all the guests i've
had on the show is that not one of the
per not one person and i'm gonna lean
into the mic here not one incredible
woman that i've had on the show is
perfect
not
one of them and that's amazing thank god
yeah no kidding right but they're not
not one person and i've had so many
incredible women and the hope of why i
say that is who the hell do you want to
be and how the hell do you get there and
show up every day and that's everything
that the women have interviewed they
didn't they weren't born great not one
of them
yeah
every time it's oh what did you learn oh
you fell on your face oh you're really
bad at that it's comical how often
people say that from therapists you know
one of like the most incredible
therapist nicole pereira she's just like
oh my god you know yeah i i went through
my own mess in order to
be a therapist and learn totally i
couldn't keep up on the parade laps when
i was racing and the parade labs are the
ones where you go real slow and you just
are in formation and keep up on those
laps
what does that mean exactly say that
again so when you um are in order of how
you're supposed to start the race from
qualifying there you get in you line up
it's like two by two all the way back
and you go really slow
and stay in formation in that two by two
until the green flag drops and then you
go as hard as you can and on those slow
little laps i couldn't keep up
right so it shows that and you know
another thing i was thinking of too is
just you know steps forward a step back
finally to arrive at your goal is that
it reminds me of something from atomic
habits um the book atomic habits and
that it's it's not it's not every little
thing that you've done even though it
might you might not see any difference
whatsoever
once you finally arrive at whatever it
is that you're seeking or your goal
even you think it just happened one day
but it didn't it happened from the point
that you started trying even though you
saw no fruits from your labor or you see
no progress or you have regression or
you get redirected or rerouted in your
life like how many times do we get
rerouted in our life and we're like that
wasn't my plan
it was all part of getting to that final
getting to that that goal or that
destination that you wanted and it was
not it was never a waste of time it's so
true and it's one of these like how do
we
even just remind ourselves that because
it's so easy to fit in like slip into
the panels like what is happening why am
i doing it that was a waste of time like
even when i think back of my eight years
of being a stay-at-home wife like it's a
waste of time but it wasn't because it
taught me so many lessons and allowed me
to never go back there um i assume
you've seen the movie karate kid
i have not actually the old movie
karateka oh my god is that what i'm
watching on netflix tonight i just need
a movie
now
not the tv show the old school movie no
i ha i really i'm not very either i've
seen a lot of funny movies but there's a
lot of movies that are classics that i
haven't seen i haven't seen star wars i
haven't seen like any of those like uh
what are the ones the furoto ones the
those futuristic
or the other one that's kind of like i
haven't seen any of them so anyway
what's up what movies do you watch then
funny ones usually okay or like really
um i love um who is it it's uh nolan
um what's his name oh jonathan nolan no
no
did inception and tenant and
like that kind of a movie those sort of
thought-provoking futuristic-ish
so i i grew up watching 80s movies and
that's why i brought it up because
there's so many of them that like
if i could go back like not even go back
if i could make movies now those are the
types of movies i would make because
they're really freaking entertaining but
the lesson is so amazing so karate kid
it's like they get him
so he gets
um he wants a teacher to like help him
like learn karate and so he goes to this
guy mr miyagi and mr miyagi starts to
give him a paintbrush and he's like
paint my fence and so for like a week he
has him painting his fence and then he's
like now wax my cars and so now for
another week he's got this kid waxing
his cars and he's like what the hell i
came to learn karate and you've just got
me freaking as your like slave basically
painting and like waxing your cars
and he starts going all right show me so
mr miyagi starts throwing soft punches
he's like now pain and he starts
blocking the pain brushes as he starts
blocking the things as if he was
painting and then he does wax on
wax
so that's where it came from he starts
blocking the punches with a wax on wax
off and the whole metaphor is waxing on
and waxing the car off is in preparation
for when you're literally he steps in
the ring he gets his ankle broken and
what does he do he gets back up and then
wins the match so it's like
yeah exactly so the idea of waxing on
and waxing off is the preparation so
while it feels like you're painting a
fence what you're actually doing is
preparing for battle yeah and so
going to the skill sets of what you're
saying is that when i didn't realize
when i was the stay-at-home wife and i
was freaking miserable and all i was
doing is trying to film my day i would
start to like
i would like go to the grocery store and
like collect coupons and how can i save
money oh my god today it's to buy toilet
rolls get a third one free so i've just
now doubled our money or tripled our
money right and so i would start to play
games just to fill my mind because
i hated being a stay-at-home wife
and now what i ended up doing i found
myself flash forward three years later
we're at quest we're building i'm
building my shipping department and i
have to budget i'm using the budgetary
mindset that i created when i was a
stay-at-home wife on how on earth i
built a production facility and a
shipping facility so now when i'm
looking at shipping labels and i'm
looking at ups versus fedex i'm looking
at costs i'm seeing who can ship quicker
it's all the skills that i freaking
learned when i was a stay-at-home wife
thinking i was just painting a fence and
then i find myself in battle at quest
where
should i realize the paint in the fence
is actually getting me you know the
building of the facility so the wax on
wax off is such a beautiful mentality
that even right now as people are
listening when they're doing things that
they're like what the hell am i doing
i'm wasting my life
going to your point of if we can reframe
it and say maybe i'm building a skill
set that i can look for look you know
use in the future then it doesn't seem
like a waste
oh man
so many gems so many lessons that you've
been able to identify in such a positive
way and also teach yourself how to
identify it is an
art to be able to shift that perception
um thank you thank you for
sharing so many lessons and thank you
for the book radical confidence i can't
wait to read it like i feel like there's
just going to be
a lot of really a lot of really great
stories and great examples of how we can
grow and evolve so
thank you for all of your deep work and
your radical confidence and honesty that
you share with everybody and i can't
wait to be on your show thank you hell
yeah homie thank you for having me on
thank you for just creating a platform
um you know where you're inspiring other
people and yeah i just think that you
know um who you are behind the scenes
also you know really does show who
you know a person really is and i've
seen you behind the scenes and how sweet
and gracious you are and wonderful i
haven't seen you in a few years but um
you know who you show up to be every day
is such a beautiful example of how
powerful women really can be so thank
you for all that you do to the world
that sounds a little like
but like seriously thank you homie and
then thank you for having me you're
welcome thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button